The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com we have
a hack day of youth today, so I'm particularly
glad that you're with me
and I'll get right into it.
We have a major, major story to start with
today.
It's really one of the biggest stories of
the year, uh, in the world of social media
and online marketing.
Uh, the issue of political ads and terms of
service has become a really huge issue and
it relates to politics so closely.
And Twitter has decided to ban all political
advertising from its platform.
Uh, the Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey says that
advertisers are getting an unfair advantage
in sending out misleading and inaccurate messages
and that Twitter is going to stop all political
ads, period.
This was announced on Twitter and a multi
tweet thread by Jack Dorsey where he said,
quote, we've made the decision to stop all
political advertising on Twitter globally.
We believe political message should reach
a political message.
Reach should be earned, not bought.
Of course, there are some claiming this is
a form of suppression of speech and it's not.
And Jack Dorsey says this, and a subsequent
tweet in this thread, quote a final note,
this isn't about free expression.
This is about paying for reach and paying
to increase the reach of political speech
has significant ramifications that today's
democratic infrastructure may not be prepared
to handle.
It's worth stepping back in order to address.
Now, interestingly, he says it first, they
thought maybe we'll ban ads just by political
candidates promoting a candidate in a particular
election, but then they correctly realize
that lots of what is going on, that that is
really political advertising is PACS that
may be supporting a candidate, which is sort
of like one level removed from the candidate.
And then you're getting to issue based stuff
that is clearly political but wouldn't be
stopped if you simply say no ads for candidates.
So they're banning all of it.
Uh, although we have to figure out what the
implementation will be.
So let's talk about that first.
But then you know, I really want to talk about
the implications and the context in which
this is taking place.
So implementation, this starts on November
22nd now.
That's about three weeks from now.
How will they decide if an ad is political
in nature because so many things are political
to some degree is an ad about keeping our
national parks clean from pro uh, pollution
and trash in the context of the climate crisis
is that political who gets to decide?
I don't know the answers to these questions.
It's going to need to be sorted out and I'm
guessing that on some level Twitter will come
up with some rubric for determining what it
is that counts as political and there may
well be some disagreement about what that
is.
The big thing here is that this is very clearly
a shot across the bow at Facebook and that
Mark Zuckerberg, you might remember and we
covered it, that Mark Zuckerberg testified
before the house last week.
It went really poorly for him.
I played the clips of Congresswoman Alexandria
Cossio Cortez asking him questions that he
wasn't even remotely able to answer in a satisfactory
way.
Her mistake was interrupting his answers.
I think that that is not the right look.
You gain nothing by interrupting Mark Zuckerberg.
If anything, you bail him out from fully being
able to expose that he doesn't know a lot
of these answers.
That's my one critique of AOC in that, but
mostly it was Zuckerberg who was visibly confused,
not just about what Facebook policies should
be from a moral, ethical or legal standpoint,
but even seemed confused about what Facebook
policies are.
Uh, and what is clear is that Facebook and
Twitter are going to be taking drastically
different approaches to this issue of political
advertising and what is involved.
Facebook is taking the ad money and they are
going to make some sort of little restrictions
around the edges to try to protect some semblance
of responsibility that they want to claim
to have about what they will allow a Mark
Zuckerberg talking about examples of, you
know, you can't target black voters.
I think he said you can't target black voters
or black predominantly black zip codes with
an ad that misstates when election day is.
That would be a form of voter suppression,
but the line between that and just a generally
dishonest ad is a blurry line.
It became very clear that it was blurry.
When Mark Zuckerberg testified Twitter is
doing something very different.
They're cutting this off at the pass.
They're saying no political ads period.
Now Jack Dorsey doesn't mention Mark Zuckerberg
specifically in his tweets, but he does say
for example, that quote, we have witnessed
many social movements reach massive scale
without any political advertising.
What he is responding to is Zuckerberg saying,
you know, if we tighten our policies on this
will disproportionately hurt grassroots groups
will disproportionately hurt challengers in
politics and we will be propping up the status
quo.
That was Mark Zuckerberg, his argument, clearly
Jack Dorsey saying he doesn't agree with.
I agree with that when he says we've seen
movements succeed even without paid political
advertising.
So I have a few thoughts on this.
First of all, remember politicians, billionaire
tech CEOs, these are not heroic actors.
We shouldn't idolize them.
Jack Dorsey made a decision that well could
be the correct moral decision, but there is
no question that part of it was a calculation
based on the PR of it based on the timing
of last week's Facebook fiasco in front of
Congress.
So, number one, let's not focus our interpretation
on the morality of ethics or ethics of the
decision.
Even if on the merits it is the right decision
and it may well be.
Secondly, I have to tell you, I know political
ads are big on Twitter.
In my experience, the problem isn't so much
the political ads, which I see very few of
and can say, I don't want to see stuff like
this.
I don't know if that's because of how I browse
Twitter.
For me, the real problem, the real battle
lines are the terms of service and enforcement
of those terms of service for users.
For me, this has always been really the issue
on Twitter.
I like the decision that was made about banning
political ads.
That's a decision Twitter can make and they
can say, we're just not gonna have that on
our platform.
Our platform will not allow a political issues
or candidates to buy influence.
They're going to have to earn it.
But what about high profile people who are
allowed to completely flout the terms of service?
For example, like Donald Trump himself.
What about the totally soft way in which Twitter
has dealt with criticism about the political
nature of it's terms of service from both
left and right, sometimes rightly, sometimes
in a completely ridiculous way without adjudicating
right now as a um, uh, a particular terms
of service decision as right or wrong Twitter
needs to deal with their terms of service
enforcement in a serious and credible way.
And I hope that they do, although this might
be a really PR friendly thing to do, banning
political ads instead of dealing with the
mess of their terms of service and more specifically
their enforcement.
One last thought on this, even if you ban
political ads in the formal sense where a
candidate can run a paid campaign, uh, there
are still ways around this candidates or issue
based organizations or packs, they can still
pay for retweets and tweets.
There are a whole bunch of ways that you can
still effectively by reach on Twitter, even
if it is strictly speaking band.
That is a bigger conversation and we'll see
if ultimately Twitter comments about that.